hi mystery recapped here today I'm going
to explain a British dystopian Thriller
film called high-rise spoilers ahead
watch out and take care
[Music]
the movie starts in a dilapidated and
totally out of order high-rise building
where trash and corpses are lying all
around the protagonist Dr Robert Liang
is one of the few survivors who's seen
Scavenging his floor until he finds a
dog Robert takes the poor animal with
him and starts feeding it however the
next second he finishes it off and spit
roasts its leg such as the situation of
the high-rise every living being even
humans are considered food following
this we are taken to three months
earlier situated in the outskirts of
London the 40-story tower has just been
constructed by esteemed architect
Anthony Royal he claims that the housing
offered by this high-rise is the most
lavish yet affordable in all of England
with amenities like Swimming Pools Spas
gyms and even primary schools for
children one could hardly argue with the
lavishness of this place in no time
hundreds and thousands of people flood
the high-rise and start living there
permanently out of the 40 floors the top
ones are occupied by the wealthiest
people while the lower ones by the poor
the disparity increases even more in the
course of the next few months as people
are categorized on the basis of the
floors they live for instance a guy who
lives on the 26th floor is considered
wealthier and more elegant than the one
on the 25th as for the people on the
ground floor they are barely considered
people for most they are just barbarians
but they don't have to use the elevator
one day Dr Robert Liang also moves into
the high-rise he has no family or
friends so he lives alone on the 25th
floor Robert loves wearing formal suits
so much that he even sleeps in them it's
either the suit or no clothes at all
there's no in between one day as he is
sunbathing on his balcony nakey a woman
from the 26th floor named Charlotte
spots him smitten with his good looks
she immediately invites him to her party
that evening there's nothing low-key
about that dong later Robert gets
dressed and heads to the school of
physiology where he works as a lecturer
and in one of his classes he gathered
some students and cuts open a human head
to describe the brain segments
unfortunately one of the students named
Monroe cannot bear the sight so he
collapses on the floor that evening
Robert attends Charlotte's party and
gets to know that she is a single mother
he then befriends a struggling filmmaker
named Wilder and his heavily pregnant
wife Helen although the latter is kind
and generous by Nature Wilder is
arrogant he doesn't miss a single chance
to flirt with other girls even if it is
in front of his wife as the party goes
on Robert gets drunk and has a lovely
time with his new friends the next
morning he wakes up hungover so he calls
his workplace and asks for a leave then
he goes to the local swimming pool with
Charlotte where he sees middle and lower
class people swimming Robert however
cannot dive into the water because he is
dressed in his formal attire wearing
anything other than that is an act of
sin for him just then a daunting looking
guy named Simmons arrives there and
takes Robert away saying that Mr Royal
wants to see him inside the elevator
Robert tries to have small talk but
Simmons completely ignores him shortly
after they arrive at Mr Royal's lavish
Penthouse where he appears to be making
some diagrams for his upcoming buildings
after welcoming Robert to his place Mr
Royal reveals that he damaged his leg in
an accident years ago so he wants it
treated as soon as possible however to
his dismay Robert mentions that he is
only a physiotherapy teacher not a
doctor nonetheless Mr Royal invites him
to his wife's party the next day you're
getting drunk and you're fixing my leg
that night Robert once again meets
Charlotte and ends up having coitus with
her unfortunately at the peak of their
romance her son walks in on them this
prompts Robert to quickly get dressed
and leave the place embarrassed the
following day he attends Mr Royal's
wife's party on the top floor only to
learn that it is an 18th century costume
party seeing him dressed in a suit
everyone makes fun of him even a student
who had passed out earlier Monroe Robert
ignores him and heads to a corner to
grab a smoke but just then Simmons
arrives and knocks him out to make
matters worse when Robert gets into the
elevator the power suddenly he goes out
trapping him inside for hours several
days pass by but the load shedding
problem has still not been resolved so
the lower floor tenants start demanding
answers against the management soon the
protests turn into riots which are led
by none other than the Arrogant
filmmaker Wilder meanwhile Robert heads
over to work and orders a brain scan of
his student Monroe the results come out
clean but Robert who is still angry
about how he was treated last night at
the party lies to Monroe that he has a
brain tumor hearing this the latter is
devastated one day to protest against
the increasing discrimination in the
high-rise Wilder organizes a party for a
bunch of kids as he is busy preparing
the food his wife Helen approaches him
and mentions that the rich guys aren't
allowing them to use the local pool it
has been weeks since she has gotten to
take a dip inside the water hearing this
the already agitated Wilder becomes even
more Furious so he rounds up all the
children and heads to the swimming pool
there he crashes the rich people's party
and humiliates them for being
self-centered and egotistical people who
only care about themselves after this he
dives into the water finally making them
leave the place unfortunately once
everyone is out of sight he finds one of
their dogs and brutally takes it out
underwater at this point the electricity
inside the high-rise has gone out and
even the backup generators have stopped
functioning leaving the people in total
darkness soon Robert arrives at the pool
to check on his friend but when he
notices the lifeless dog he is
devastated in the next scene the
residents of the lower floors led by
Wilder start partying in the hallway
although the situation is very dire and
the disparity between the rich and poor
keeps on increasing they simply want to
have some fun tonight in the midst of
all this Wilder clashes with Simmons and
beats him to a pulp his wife and
Charlotte noticed this so they decide to
let him do whatever he wants soon Robert
also joins the party and starts dancing
like a maniac meanwhile unbeknownst to
everyone a depressed and drunk Monroe
goes to the edge of the building and
commits the unthinkable the loud bang
startles everyone and when they go to
check all they see is a bloody mess
Robert is devastated to learn that his
prank has gone too far unfortunately
things get even worse in the morning
along with the electricity the water
supply also Runs Out leaving the tenants
in a State of Shock this makes Wilder
loses cool so he decides to make a
documentary of the high-rise and submit
it to the authorities Wilder is
especially angry about the fact that an
innocent person is committed the
unthinkable yet not even a single cop
has come to investigate the case he
believes that Mr Royal has paid off the
entire police department to stay away
from his projects upstairs the upper
class guys discuss how the poor people
have suddenly gotten out of control one
of them suggests teaching them a lesson
by throwing an even nicer party while
another guy says that they should elute
all the remaining supplies left in the
high-rise the latter's idea is voted by
the majority and hence they form a gang
and start their own reign of terror over
the next few days the situation inside
the building continues to deteriorate
due to the lack of electricity and
proper drinking water the remaining Food
Supplies also start dwindling at a rapid
rate moreover crimes like robbery
assault and even kidnapping become
rampant the people slowly start going
insane and Robert isn't an exception
although he goes to work every day he
cannot focus due to the lack of proper
nutrients in his body causing him to
fall asleep most of the time when things
get out of control he quits work and
starts exercising 10 hours a day the gym
is littered with garbage bags and human
excrete but Robert doesn't care he just
wants to exercise in his formal clothes
one day as Wilder is filming the chaotic
situation inside the supermarket the
rich gang from upstairs arrives and
attacks him they beat him up mercilessly
and dump him into the garbage disposal
area meanwhile Robert also gets into a
fight with a stranger over a bucket of
pain despite having never laid hands on
the person before he punches the guy
repeatedly rupturing his eyeballs it
appears as if the situation inside the
high-rise has turned everyone into
animals that evening the pregnant Helen
visits Robert who gladly shows her
around his apartment one thing leads to
another and they start getting intimate
meanwhile upstairs Mr Royal is still
working on his new designs despite
everything that has happened with this
one there are several Intruders who have
barged inside his house most of whom are
having intercourse with random people
just then Simmons informs Mr Royal that
his wife has been kidnapped by the lower
tenants they are currently mistreating
her by making her dance hearing this Mr
Royal gets enraged and heads downstairs
with a golf club eventually after
navigating through the desolate floors
he finds his wife and somehow brings her
back with him elsewhere a bloodied
Wilder staggers back to his apartment he
is now hell-bent on murdering Mr Royal
as he blames the architect for all the
ongoing problems to his luck he finds Mr
Royal's housemaid and coerces
information out of her he also borrows
her pistol promising to pay her in the
millions once he gets the job done
following this he heads to Charlotte's
apartments and forces himself onto her
like an animal the poor woman begs and
pleads for help but so are hundreds of
other women who are being harassed just
like her that evening the guys at the
top floor find out about Wilder's
activity and decide to take action
Simmons suggests that they ask Robert to
lobotomize him Mr Royal believes that
this is a bad idea but when the guys
insist he gives in following this the
guys butcher Mr Royal's pet horse and
eat it for dinner as there is no food
left in the supermarkets the strange
thing is that despite everything
happening no one wants to leave the
building in the next scene Robert
approaches Wilder in his apartment and
interrogates him about his recent
activities the latter explains that he
feels guilty for what he has done but it
is the situation that has turned him
into this animal he also laments about
his inability to save his family and the
fellow tenants who are dying every day
due to the carelessness of the
management hearing this Robert realizes
that Wilder is actually the sanest man
in the entire building so he drops his
plan of lobotomizing Wilder and leaves
however just as he reaches a bit far
Simmons and his men Ambush him from
behind and carry him upstairs there they
beat him up for not obeying their orders
and take him to the edge of the building
the guys are about to throw him
downstairs but just then Mr Royal
arrives and stops them despite
everything that has happened the
architect of the high-rise still
believes that he can make things work
and revert everything back to normal so
he doesn't want any more people to die
at night Robert Charlotte and some other
lower floor people have dinner with Mr
Royal where he explains that he is soon
going to renovate the high-rise he has
already separated a large budget for it
all he needs is a good engineer suddenly
Helen who is also there goes into labor
and gives birth to a baby boy this makes
all the people present there happy and
they start celebrating with loud shears
unfortunately their happy moment is soon
cut short when Wilder arrives there with
his gun he spots Mr Royal and initially
chastises him for all the Havoc he has
laid upon the people then he pulls the
trigger and Strikes the architect right
in the chest killing him on the spot
with this Wilder's mission is finally
accomplished and he starts laughing
maniacally like this
however as he is about to depart the
angry relatives of Mr Royal surround him
and brutally execute him with their
knives Robert watches all of this from a
distance he is neither concerned nor
terrified he just wants to go to his
room and change into a new suit the
following morning Robert and Charlotte
give Mr Royal a proper burial in the
swimming pool while the rich women at
the top floor start looking after
Helen's infant child as the days pass
Robert starts going insane he refers to
himself in the third person and keeps
acting as if he is a doctor the only
good thing is that he and Charlotte
start living together then one day while
he is searching for food he stumbles
upon Mr Royal's Dog the movie ends as
Helen's son listens to the radio where
Margaret Thatcher is giving a speech she
says where there is State capitalism
there can never be political Freedom
little on the nose there Margaret
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching